silicons have a bad reputation and they
really don't deserve it we really have
to thank them because they
revolutionized makeup before silicons
were a thing you had to be really
talented to apply foundation they would
dry too fast for you to spread them out
or they would dry too slow and move
around and bunch up in crease all the
time and then came silicons they are a
huge family of ingredients with lots of
different properties but they tend to
play well with each other so you'll see
them turn up together a lot of the time
in products silicons are really good at
spreading smoothly they're good at
staying wet for long enough so you can
smooth it out and move it around bit but
when they set they can set and the film
that they form is flexible enough to
move with your face and stay breathable
but it won't bunch up too much or rub
off on stuff too easily a lot of people
think that silicons and skincare
products break them out and it is
possible that they can but it's a lot
more likely that it is something else
silicons are so compatible with our
bodies that they used in medical
applications and almost every liquid
foundation out there these days use the
silicon and very few people can't use
any liquid foundations